In today's video, we'll be using one
prompt, generating three AI built
websites, and then we'll be testing the
websites for design, performance, SEO,
and go readiness. Let's go ahead and get
started. This is the prompt in which
we'll be using. Essentially, we just
made up a business here in Toronto. So,
the first tool that I used was
Hostinger. So, Hostinger has an AI built
uh built in. So you can actually uh
generate full uh scale websites and then
publish those sites over to your domain.
So this is the website that we got back
from Hostinger. As we can see here, very
simple. Looks pretty decent. I'm not
going to lie. Let's go to the mobile
view. Mobile view is, you know, pretty
standard website here. I like this icon.
Um how it kind of goes across. I like
that animation style there. Looks pretty
decent.
Um we get some pricing. We get some
FAQs. We get some
testimonials.
Yeah, I would say a pretty good site.
Service areas. Okay, this is good. It
would be nice if we can click into that,
but this was one shot, so we can't
expect it to have everything finished
about us. Again, not bad. Not bad. Not
bad website at all. Now, the second site
that I used to build the website was
Bluehost. So, Bluehost also has an AI
website builder. Now, here is the site
that we're able to get back. And um I
like this. This actually looks really,
really good. Um I like the way it's laid
out. I like the design. I like the
animations.
Can use a little bit more color. And
this is what it looks like as well on
mobile. Looks pretty modern. Decent. I
would like a little bit more imagery and
a little bit more colors, but overall
not bad. And if we go to services, we
can actually see the services as well.
And lastly, we can see the projects that
it's went ahead and included here. So,
in terms of design uh look and feel, I
would say that both of these websites
did a good job at designing um these
specific sites. Now, lastly, let's go
ahead and use Rankite AI to generate
this same website. So, of course, I'm
going to enter in the same prompt here.
Anyway,
after a few steps of setting it up, our
website is now live. So, we can go ahead
and take a look at it. We're definitely
going to have to revisit um our
onboarding process for ranksite because
it is much quicker to generate website
using hostinger or using blue host. So,
we can see here's the website that we
get back from um from site rank. As you
can see, it looks really really good. We
have our contact form. We have our
services, our about us, our work, blog,
so on and so forth. In terms of design,
I would definitely give number one to
Blue Host. I think the design is really,
really well done. It's modern. It's not
generic like every other website. I like
the animations. I would just add a
little bit more color, but overall, I
really, really like the design from Blue
Host. And then Hostinger and um Site
Rank is second and third. In terms of
ease of use, all of the tools were
pretty easy to use. Of course, having a
AI chat builder is much much simpler to
generate your content because you just
put in your prompt and you can get your
generations in just one or two clicks.
While on rankside, we had to go through
a module which was a couple more steps,
but again, it allowed us to really
choose the services and the locations
that we want to. We are working on
creating a way in which you can chat
more natively with um the AI to then
build your website out. So, it's going
to be much easier to generate your
sites. So now that our sites are
generated, we all know you can have a
beautiful website, but it doesn't mean
it's actually going to rank or do well.
So in terms of SEO optimization and
actually growing your website, I think
that's where Rankite really really
separates itself from these other AI
site builders. Like these site builders
are great, don't get me wrong. Right
now, you don't have actually have a plan
of action of what to do next. You kind
of have to figure it out as you go. So
with Rankside we can see here that it
gives us more of a plan in which we can
follow to grow our website. If you look
at our dashboard we can see that we
actually have some things that we can
do. We can upgrade our NAP. We can add
more information about our business. But
if you go over to my sites we can see
the pages that we need to further
create. And the big difference is with
our content, our content from rankset is
going to be SEO and geo optimized,
especially when it comes to these
service pages. Now, while design can be
good, if you don't have good SEO or geo
optimized content on your website, good
internal linking, and built with a
foundation of SEO and GEO, it will not
rank and do well. So again, if we go
back over to um Ranksite, we can see
here that now for each one of our
services, we have our location pages as
well. So we have about 28 pages that we
can create right off the bat. So let's
go ahead and generate some of these
pages so I can show you what it looks
like and the difference that you get
with Rank Site. So while those pages are
generating, I did mention SEO and GEO
optimization. If we go over to SEO and
GEO, we can run an audit to see how our
website is doing. So, we can see all of
the technical aspect of your SEO site is
going to be baked into every single site
with Rankite. Your robots.txt, LLM.txt,
txe AI JSON endpoints sitemap is also
active catch headers and every single
page is going to be lightning fast in
terms of how uh it loads for your users.
So for example, let's go ahead and do a
little bit of a test here. So I'm going
to go to page speed insights.
We're going to test
the Blue Host site and we're also going
to test the new site that we generated
from site rank. Another extremely useful
feature is our blogging feature from
rank site. So what you can do is with a
new website you can actually go ahead
and click post ideas, click generate
post ideas and we will find you ideas
based upon your website. Then you can
take those ideas and turn it into a
blogging automation that creates blogs
on any cadence that you choose or you
can generate a blog post um
individually. So we can see here we get
blog post ideas. How much does basement
basement waterproofing cost in Toronto
in 2025? Let's go ahead and create a
draft for this. I'm going to change this
to 2026.
And then we can go ahead and generate
with AI. So we can go ahead and generate
our blog post as well. get ideas for a
blog post that allows us to grow our
website. Again, I'm not bashing these
tools. They're really, really good. Blue
Host and Hostinger are really, really
good at generating your first shot
website. But in terms of growing your
websites for yourself or for your
client, that's where Rankite really,
really separates itself. Let's go ahead
and compare the page speed insights from
the site that we built with Blue Host
versus Rankite. So first off in terms of
mobile from Blue Host we got 72
performance 91 accessibility 77 best
practices 92 SEO and one out of two
agentic browsing for rank site we got 85
performance so a little bit higher we
can definitely prove this 96
accessibility and then 100 best
practices 100 SEO and three out of three
aentic browsing in terms of desktop blue
host got 98 performance 91 accessibility
100 best practices 92 SEO and one out of
two agentic browsing. Now site rank got
91 performance, 100 best practices, 96
accessibility, 100 SEO, but most
importantly three out of three agentic
browsing. So that means that our website
is now browsable website for AI agents.
It is AI search ready. If your website
is not AI search ready in 2026, you will
fall behind. you will not be able to get
ranked or mentioned in AI search which
will bring targeted traffic over to your
website. So again while this was a
beautiful site it is not SEO or geo
optimized compared to rank sites.
Another huge huge benefit of rank site
is that we have a apps marketplace. So
that means you can add different apps to
your website without paying anything
additional. And this site chatbot is
already already going to use the
information that the website is built
on. So you don't have to actually do
anything. You just have to turn it on
and you have to just turn on your cookie
consent as well. So if I go back over to
my dashboard, go over to my pages, we
can see that these are the new pages
that we generated. If we take a look at
the pages, we can see it's very very
indepth, right? It's not like a couple
of sentences. Very in-depth SEO
optimize. You have your highlight cards
as well. And we can go ahead and change
our imagery. and it's taking the imagery
from the blog post that we are
generating. Let's go back over to my
site. Let's go over to my page. Let's go
ahead and publish this.
And then we're going to add the blog.
So, this is the blog as well. And this
is the location page that we generated.
Again, as you can see here, the content
is HTML
and um loads really, really fast and is
SEO optimized. So, again, we're going to
change this imagery as well. And also
each page is going to have its own JSON
LD schema. So everything is schema
markedup. And Google absolutely loves
schema markup. And you don't have to do
anything additional. You don't have to,
you know, create the schema yourself.
Upload onto rank site. Everything is
done for you automatically, including
your SEO title and your meta
description. So again, we're going to
click publish here.
We're going to publish this blog post as
well.
Let's actually just let's go ahead and
take a look at the blog post as well.
Looks really really good. Again,
in-depth stuff here, right? Everything
is SEO and geo optimized. We're going to
click publish and then we're going to
publish our site. So, it's going to show
all of our new changes. And if you guys
notice, I did all of this on a free plan
with site rank. I don't need to have a
paid plan. I just need to have my open
router API key. So, here's the full
site. Now, as you can see, our cookie
consent is now activated and also our
chatbot. So, I can ask it what services
do you offer, right? And then it tells
me where and I can go there and read
more about those services, right? So, if
I scroll down, we can see our services
here. We would have to generate some of
these other ones. But this is the
article or sorry, the page that we
generated on interior waterproofing. As
you can see, interior waterproofing
looks really, really good. Beautiful,
beautiful imagery.
HTML content here, right?
We get a custom. This is all custom. So,
this changes for every single one.
Custom highlight card related pages for
SEO. So, I can click onto any one of
these pages. It's going to take me over
to a related page. Every page is
internally linked as well. As you can
see, looks beautiful, right? If we go
over to our location, here's our
location pages as well.
We can view all service page. Then we
can go ahead and click into any one of
these and it's going to take us into
that service page. So everything is
internally linked. Everything has
hierarchy and SEO optimization. If you
go over to the blog section, we can see
our blog here. Again, looks absolutely
beautiful. There's a nice HTML element
here that allows you to be able to
scroll through with your tags and your
CTAs, everything all integrated onto
your blog and your service pages. So,
while with some of these other uh
builders you can build a little bit
nicer looking websites, when it comes to
functional websites that actually grow
and actually brings you in traffic and
is actually useful to getting you
qualified leads, that's where Rankite
really separates itself and allows you
to add these powerful add-ons to your
website, have powerful SEO and geo
optimization without you having to do
any heavy lifting on your end. We take
care of everything. You just tell us
what your website is about. So, I hope
that you guys enjoyed this quick
comparison. If you want to take
advantage of Rankside, we do have a
lifetime deal going on where you get $70
off. I'll leave a link in description
below today's video. Any questions, let
me know and I'll see you in the next
one. Take care.